d'étrelles en pleine nature et des
coureurs qui vont au bout d'eux-mêmes
voici le programme de la 12e édition de
l'eco-trail le rendez-vous proposera le
17 mars des courses de 18 30 45 et 80 km
entre l'ouest parisien et la tour eiffel
plus de douze mille participants sont
attendus sur cette épreuve
c'est devenu le plus gros rendez-vous
trail de début de saison où on peut
accueillir des élites les meilleures
élites de la discipline et c'est aussi
en fonction des différentes et
différents formats de course de 18 aux
80 c'est hyper ouvert ce qui fait que
les gens on en a de plus en plus qui
s'inscrivent de plus en plus tôt donc
nous nous inscrivons dès le mois de
juillet ça veut dire près de neuf mois
avant avant l'événement et on est
complet on est complet au mois de
février
parmi les participants fabien parmentier
à coureur originaire de montigny le
bretonneux le runner a déjà participé à
11 édition de l'eco trail et repartir à
cette année sur le 80 km le départ est à
quelques kilomètres de chez moi
et puis ça permet surtout à ma famille
de me suivre en fait sur sur la totalité
du parcours
donc voilà c'est ma course le cas là moi
quoi avec le temps fabien parmentier
connaît parfaitement les pièges à éviter
sur ce départ à domicile depuis l'île de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
faut se mettre dedans effectivement faut
rentrer dans la course retrouver le bon
rythme faut éviter de pas se faire
d'entorse parce qu'effectivement on part
sur la base de loisirs de saint quentin
et puis on part dans un une espèce de
chant qui est relativement beau ce n'est
pas évident pour les scheer donc faut
faire faut rester attentif aux trouver
le bon rythme parce se cramer trop vite
une stratégie qui l'aidera peut-être à
réaliser son objectif boucler cet ultra
trail avec un temps compris entre 8h30
et 9h30